[Applause]
let's deliberate to wait the doesn't
sound right let's get our singing voices
ready like that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning believe nation Wow excited
Nina there is more excited to go today
hey all right now we're going home no
we're going to go to the entrepreneur
conference all day long no we'll get it
go going to go set up some new
businesses okay we're going back to yeah
we're heading up magic kingdom we need
some more fun the kids are going to
behave and everything's going to be
saying [ __ ] and everything is going
to be fantastic we're a little bit
earlier than yesterday we got a better
parking spot I'll admit makes me happy
as a hot dog when they're ready to go
home I get on the train
[Music]
what's Nina wearing to believe here
rotate inward
I
the cute I like watching you walk
certainly miss be talking hit what did
you discover Nina home
ye or the specific technique is you are
[Music]
me mr. nut but in line let's celebrate
to wager doesn't sound right all right
wait in the food hey how was the veena
Nina Nina reached out and touched up she
was touching into slavery
okay next up my train let's do it this
is the lineup we have to go through I
was the guy right I wasn't my body I was
it the fun look great goofy knee for the
goofy hat man
oh I don't think it's getting very good
at driving
Lena
oh I was it he said last year that you
till last year how was it Stephanie
everybody going to go meet me Disney
characters and then go eat we're gonna
meet guys
[Music]
he's a garrison goofy baby like your
heart now he got jealous his goofy
[Music]
alright it's lunch time we got clam
chowder's tuna sandwiches apple juices
yogurt
macaroni and cheese chicken pot pies and
tuna sandwiches what do we think guys
ready to eat all right that was it
amazing Jimmy team is happy because
weight is getting warmer but you've got
some rock solid look we're all in our
believe Woody's hit me I didn't mean to
do that what's up baby baby next up the
little mermaid say let's go let's go
means every chillin in the car show
okay we got let's go on to the sea ok
good Nina hey dang night all right thank
you need a pan
[Music]
how is it you're flying
alright I've got to go film a video for
the channel so Nina's gonna take the
kids to do the teacups we spit in a
circle and then on the merry-go-round
that hopefully wise be enough time to
film a video but you guys one of the
things you get when you're still in
public you get people looking at you
wondering what is this guy doing you
have talked loudly so everything for the
camera shake it up in here the more you
do it the more you just get used to it
more you know what I don't care about
what these people think I'm more about
making something that you guys are going
to love and enjoy so I got that done
pretty quickly actually surprisingly
fast so I'm going to see if I can pick
up a copy to copy a cocky ranin actress
she's pretty tired and then meet up with
the kids
[Music]
polemical into bath today
[Music]
all right finally I run off the coffee
official Brazil longest line that Disney
longer than any line we've been in and
longer than your meeting up my videos
but we got the coffee let's go pnina and
make your happy road okay knee the
accident
they're fun
[Music]
yummy
right now what we're doing is meetings
el sesame wants to meet Belle Nina wants
to meet Belle 20 and even with me Belle
we're drifting wants to meet Belle and I
want to film come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I wasn't mr. you gotta bookmark unions
the wreath all right
[Music]
we're going to show
he was going to call CEO pinilla Kiki
Stefan present
I won't be looking inside but you guys
ready for a show all right Hayden you
ready for a show no all right here we go
all right we're coming out he really
seemed United satellite what's up the
added stuff hurt the last year we really
okay but the real question we want to
know is did Nina fall asleep she fell
asleep you know why this is why her
headdress on my shoulder I felt like
this up like that we're doing this time
soon took a lot which left a little bit
okay last round of the day what's the
last part of the day let's go hit it up
we're going to take this on
[Music]
time for a favor right let's get our
singing voices ready like that
[Music]
this is my
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
bar
all they have to be going on
[Music]
it's time for our last stop of the day
what are we doing look at this lineup to
get ice cream storybook treats it's
almost starbucks level alright it's ice
cream time what do you think boys they
got strawberry sharing the strawberry
the girls are sharing the strawberry go
eat yummy yeah all right Oh Lena
stealing my chocolate Nina stealing mine
no no yeah we got each other the lineup
Knox will but quality ice cream alright
guys thank you for joining us today why
do we have fun yeah alright we're going
to head off to Hollywood studios and
Jedi training next up on our trip thank
you guys again we hope you continue to
there you go holy believe I would hurt
your one word is everyone who steal the
show thanks guys you soon